adam levine is showing off his new face
ink but the big question is is it real
it's a little crazy while stepping out
with his wife biatti prinsloo at an
event in miami the maroon 5 front man
showed off his new tattoo
now look closely or you might miss it
yep that's a giant rose tattoo on his
face you know i was always a huge fan
adam's new tat was first revealed by
biatti on her instagram story that's
adam mugging for the camera and that's
the rose running down the left side of
his temple to his cheek now why would
adam have a giant rose tattoo on his
face well the flower does have special
significance in the singer's life
first it's their eldest daughter's name
dusty rose and it's the name of adam and
biati's new tequila line cali rosa rosa
is rose in spanish me and adam
are huge tequila drinkers we love
tequila so even though roses hold
importance in the levine household it
turns out adam's face tat yeah it's not
real this message is from my mother i do
not have a tattoo on my face
the girls like you singer seemingly
notice the chatter about his alleged new
ink so he took to his instagram story to
explain there's those that help me know
that i am too vain i'm too
vain to get a tattoo on my face i'll cut
through the rest of this but knowing the
face has got to stay the same so for now
seems adam isn't adding any more tattoos
but what about expanding his family i
was just like don't even think about it
but i do want also want like five kids
when eti chatted with biati last month
she gushed over her man their two
daughters and said they're open to
expanding the family there's no um
limits to it i think it's just kind of
like where we are in our life and just
with covet too i was
just seeing them together i'm like maybe
we should have a third just to you know
have more kids
because it was so sweet to see but then
i don't know i don't know never say
never
[Music]